wir sind wieder auf an dem checkpoint
außerhalb von czilinsky mir war der
territorialen armee wir waren ja schon
die tage davor da hatten wir dieses
ikonische bild mit den kinder die haben
jetzt noch mal gemalt hier wir können
das noch mal sehen das ist eine
schulklasse die sich dieses bild hier
die den soldaten hier und in den
territorialen kräften das bild gemalt
hat das sind so diese kleinen
unterstützung sachen und was wir eben
jetzt auch im gespräch gerade mit den
männern hier die hier die checkpoints
kontrollieren beziehungsweise
aufrechterhalten um zu verhindern dass
eben russische saboteure in die stadt
einfallen was sie eben heute morgen eben
gesagt haben sie sich sehr darüber
gefreut haben war eben die lieferung der
deutschen anti tank miss als
panzerfäuste die eben hier angekommen
sein soll man hat eben auch gepostet in
bildern in videos wie man stolz die
waffen jetzt trägt das sind so kleine
motivationsschübe die im moment hier
durch die stadt gehen und
auch die menschen hier erreichen dass
sie merken sie werden nicht alleine
gelassen und das hat auch ist auch
wirkungsvoll halt im kampf gegen die
russen was eben noch ganz besonders
bemerkenswert ist dass sie hier auch in
der stadt immer wieder hören jetzt die
bereitschaft der freiwilligen die sich
jetzt melden vor allen dingen aus dem
ausland sie wächst von tag zu tag also
wir haben gehört dass mittlerweile 40
tausend kämpfer international also aus
der ganzen welt ukrainer sich freiwillig
gemeldet haben um eben für ihr land zu
kämpfen die dann eben hier in die
ukraine kommen möchten polen über andere
länder rumänien um sich dann hier den
verteidigungs kräften anzuschließen und
eine ganz andere noch solidarische
geschichte die auch ganz spannend war
die wir heute auch gehört haben ist das
zum beispiel die ganzen apartments die
bei airbnb sind die also vermietet
werden können die werden vom ausland
gemietet und zwar nicht
dass man drin wohnen will oder dass man
hier irgendwelche leute reinbringen
möchte in die appartements sondern
darüber möchte man geld spenden das
heißt man bezahlt das appartement und
spendet somit für die ukraine die das
wiederum für die menschen hier benutzen
da müssen also mittlerweile mehrere
millionen euro zusammengekommen sein
mieter während du sprichst fahren autos
an dir vorbei du stehst an einem
checkpoint offenbar werden die jetzt
dort aktuell nicht kontrolliert
jedenfalls so wie es von hier aus
aussieht wie können die ukraine
überhaupt erkennen dass in diesen autos
beispielsweise nicht irgendwelche
saboteure russische saboteure sind genau
darum geht es ja das einzige an dieser
saboteure zu vermeiden die sich ja auch
dann beispielsweise autos mit
ukrainischen kennzeichen nehmen könnten
das ist richtig also dass der schein
trügt jetzt so ein bisschen
normalerweise wird hier kontrolliert ihr
habt wahrscheinlich jetzt 23 autos
gesehen die kennen sich dann die dann
durch fahren wir waren gestern abend
hier wird sehr streng kontrolliert hier
werden die koffer räume durchsucht halt
nach waffen nach eventuell sprengstoff
das eben die angst groß da ist das eben
einfallende russen hier in der stadt
sensible kritische infrastruktur im
falle eines angriffes dann beschädigen
das sind elektrizitätswerke das sind
auch
gouverneurs häuser das sind stromleitung
jetzt wird sie ein bisschen laut die
fällen hier die bäume weil sie das holz
auch brauchen um hier ein bisschen in
diesen tonnen feuer zu machen weil es
war heute nacht wieder zehn grad zwölf
grad - es ist eiskalt wir können auch
mal rüber schwenken auch hier die seite
wurde abgefälscht und zwar nicht nur
wegen des teilweise sondern eben damit
man auch ein freies schussfeld hat wenn
von dieser seite die panzer kommen also
hier ist man vorbereitet sieht natürlich
immer alles ein wenig
provisorisch aus was hier passiert auch
die bewaffnung aber das täuscht wir
waren ja hier sind hier überall
molotow-cocktails versteckt man hat ja
auch noch andere waffen lagern eines
angriffes oder falls es hier in den
checkpoint zu gefechten kommen sollte
also man ist schon hier vorbereitet bei
dieser territorial armee um eventuell
dann angreifende einheiten zu bekämpfen
zu können vielen dank peter hell mit
dieser eindruck vor ort dankeschön peter